hello everybody welcome back to another
evident caitlyn podcast the show that
has 10,000 spoons when all you need is a
knife do you think we're not fulfilling
their needs oh oh yeah you're right
that's a bad thing to start a podcast
well it's not my fault is andrew bills
fault cuz he submitted that intro and if
you go on and submitted an intro to go
ahead and tweet us at twitter with
hashtag EK podcast intros will not be
held responsible but thank you Andrew
bills for submitting that intro I didn't
I didn't fully think it through about
like what the meaning of that was lowkey
insult so speaking of low-key insults
YouTube has stopped how I can like see
if I can make the transition youtube has
stopped showing everybody how the exact
number of subs that you have on a
channel so that people can't loki insult
you by unsubscribing
that's and like you like you can see
every single one does that does that
work sort of I kind of failed at both
things I tried to make a transition it
didn't work I try to introduce the next
topic and I did in a confusing way that
probably has people confused so to
clarify YouTube for the longest time has
displayed the exact number of
subscribers that a channel has that's
via their like public API and there are
websites like social blade I think is
the most common that will show you your
live subscriber count going up and down
yeah so it's like you have the power to
like like you can go to anyone's each
and YouTube channel and you can
unsubscribe and subscribe and in real
time you'll see the number on their
channel go up or down so it's like you
felt like you had that control which is
interesting and you can also like track
someone's channel over time and I think
that I'm not exactly sure why YouTube
did that's this but I think that it
might have to do something with like
people losing a whole bunch of subs in
reaction to this or that and like
I think it was I think it was um
especially after the like James Charles
Tati thing which if you guys aren't sure
what I'm talking about I'm not gonna go
into the full details but basically it
was a YouTube feud involving the like
most subscribers lost and I think most
subscribers gained in a day yeah and I
think seeing that live count like fuels
more people to join in on the like mass
unsubscribes where people are trying to
like cancel a youtuber yeah so now like
when you're when you have I think
they're truncating into basically like
three numbers or something like three or
four digits it's like I'm not sure
they're ever gonna do more than that so
in the hundreds yeah so you can get like
you know going up but like starting in a
thousand or so they'll say like 1.2 3k
and then when you get to like the ten
thousands I think it only goes like like
11k 12 K 13 K like thirteen point one it
might well you start losing digits as
you go up and once you're like passed a
million the only digit people will be
able to see is if you gain or lose a
million no no I think it's like like 1.1
million 1.2 million but like 100 no once
you're in the millions that's it well no
no I was gonna ask cuz we saw like a
screenshot of pewdiepies but it's
different cuz now he's it's like one
from like 100 101 it was just like one
day it's like YouTube says hey he got
enough million more subs or something
you know yeah and of course like on the
back end it's still all tracked
individually but like public-facing
the number is truncated I think so that
people losing and gaining subs isn't as
big of a thing it isn't as much news
yeah and I guess like if they if they
lose or gain enough it's still gonna be
a big enough number to show up yeah I
think I think what they're hoping is
that like it won't gain traction as
easily because like leading up to that
we're like leading up to where it's a
big enough chunk to make a change people
won't see it so maybe it'll loose steam
before it like gets to that yeah like
spot where it's big enough to show the
difference and this is us just come
Gaston we have no clue we have no insert
and no insider information that's the
one thing we can definitely state for
sure is like how this change makes us
feel because I have mixed feelings both
positive and negative and I think that
if we had of just come into the system
and this is how it was would be like
okay that's just how it is but we're
kind of used to seeing the real-time
data
yeah well and to give an example is like
with Instagram when I go to our
Instagram page its truncated yeah and
I'm sure you can go farther back and see
like details but you know we're like
forty point three K followers yeah
and it only goes up every now and then
because like it doesn't show you any
more details I've never been obsessed
with that number and I've never been
obsessed with that for YouTube we are
constantly checking it too much but I
don't think it's because I mean maybe
it's partially because it was a full but
also it's because YouTube is like the
main part of our business it's the main
part of our business and also a side
thing and also with Instagram you're
posting fairly regularly so you never
know what your gaming subs from with
YouTube you can actually you can check
it yeah but it's like such a pain that I
just never do it I know follow us on
Instagram please I have because we both
great content over there I don't care if
if we grow on Instagram as much long
term I do care long term I care but like
I don't obsess over every post you know
what I mean and I don't UPS us daily
over the subs because we have a healthy
amount of caring which and healthy means
not too much not too little yeah we
didn't care at all well I guess it
wouldn't be good for our Instagram
account because would never post you
know I mean yeah I guess what I mean by
care or not caring is they don't obsess
we don't obsess that's it yeah and if we
start losing subs over there we would be
you know it's like you you do care
you're not obsessed with YouTube we go
check multiple times a day because we
can check in real time how many we got
that our you know and it's mainly via
social blade which is a site that
is gonna be absolutely destroyed now I
think but you know we would see like why
is it going up now what is happening you
know and we will try to look at all the
data and figure it all out when really
we should just be and nothing it takes
away that much time from us creating new
good content but it does take up a
decent chunk of our brain space yeah
that's that's true I guess I mean I
don't think I'm gonna obsess over it
less just because I can't see it I think
I might really because I was about like
you know we were at dinner and like
Caitlyn was picking up something or like
like I don't know why but I have
instinct to like check what are some
subs were app for today like how many
subs have we gotten today like what's
the hell how are things like you know
checking it's kind of like you we have
this like baby that we're checking in on
it's like how are you right now how are
you right now breathing I'm so
everything was wrong yesterday it seems
to be like when the change officially
took well yesterday when we're recording
this it's it's the agent today
so it's Wednesday so it's on the 17th of
September is when the change seemed to
go into effect yeah yeah we're recording
a little early this week yeah and so I
was doing just that I was like I don't
know how many like subs were added so
far today and I reloaded socialblade and
when you lose subs it's red and I saw
like a red no significant number is like
negative 300 400 300 and I was like
what's happening did we do something
wrong yeah somebody canceling it just
like did someone write a mean post about
us or something something I got out yeah
so I was like oh my god and then I've
realized because the reason I had
checked oh the reason I checked us cuz
we had just passed we just went into
four hundred thirty thousand subscribers
I mean every 10,000 subscribers we have
like a little letter board and I changed
the number this was like oh we have 420
subs we have 430 or 420k for no 30k and
so I got excited I was gonna go show
Evan and then I was like I wonder how
we've gotten but when I saw the red
number I also saw that it still said 429
something yeah I was like oh well that's
weird too
oh I mean you thought we'd lost no no it
it triggered something in me too to
think like well it's like the YouTube
app is gonna be more correct so that me
something's wrong with socialblade oh
yeah yeah yeah but we had a moment of
panic because we've never had a red day
at least this we start checking yeah in
the early days like before I knew
socialblade was the thing we might have
had some bad days because we always lose
subs pretty much every day but we never
lost more than we've gained yeah yeah I
think long-term this might be a healthy
change for us I mean if we want to we
can look back at our data we still have
like all the data how much we gain each
day what videos did so it's like as
creators we're not losing much
functionality I mean if I really want to
do it I can like at a certain at nine
o'clock every morning I can see because
we can still see our exact number of
subs on the YouTube studio trap so I can
look track it yourself
oh no I like write down like when you
wake up what's the number app and then
they like do the math I know but like
see that's that's an unhealthy level of
obsession I know but but but if I'm
obsessed enough to do that then
socialblade is just made it work
YouTube's just made it work now I'm
obsessed and I'm doing math danger
danger I think that long term they'll go
back to it I think that this will be
good because we won't think on it too
much and if like okay let's go into an
analytics period and let's like look at
the data see which videos are like doing
it for our channel and are healthy and
like what isn't doing as well and like
let's dive into the data we can do that
consciously instead of it being an
unconscious thing or like it's something
that's in the back of our head too much
that's kind of like plaguing us that is
true healthier I still look at it like
more on a weekly basis on a daily basis
because there's more fluctuation in a
day than there is week to week yes or
like between days than there is between
weeks yeah so I think it is generally
good all right now just Disney
xiety yeah I think like in in the long
term it'll be good and also I think it's
kind of good for other people not to
obsess over it too yeah that is true
yeah like not just like a channel owners
but also like the general public
hopefully it'll like I mean if the goal
is to stop or slow down to cancel
culture hopefully will discourage that I
don't know I don't know I mean sometimes
yeah they're the cancel culture is like
a whole nother thing but I think that
since it's such a recent change I'm not
sure how much we'll see the results
right now yeah it'll probably yeah but I
mean like if you look at the general
opinion all mine most craters are like
this is horrible
please change it back I do not like this
in any way because I know well you know
what would have been nice is if cuz you
you can I mean do we have an account on
socialblade or do we just we do have an
account it would be nice is if you
logged in to your own account on
socialblade you could still see your own
detailed numbers and I know it's not
social blade is doing it's YouTube's
doing cuz YouTube's not sending them at
the day it would be nice but the thing
is and and that would be kind of nice
but at the same time YouTube would have
to work with like third-party companies
to have a special API here's a better
thing what's that YouTube should just
provide us our hourly sub data yeah they
can totally do that I don't think they
do they don't they don't they don't have
real-time graphs
yeah especially on like launch day now
they do have real-time click-through
data now which is like almost more
important that's true for videos on a
per video it's just a vanity number
anyway yeah nothing matters more than
your views and subs really help worth of
you so please subscribe to all our
channels but also but I think that that
um it will be hopefully a long-term gain
and happiness which brings us to our
main topic which is the nine keys to
happiness
you've been very on top of your
transitions I try but before we get to
that we have a quick sponsored message
from Squarespace quick sponsored message
from our sponsor
I'm slightly better at words than that
even though words are hard I'm wearing
it for those of you who guys who are
just listening I recently had to update
our gaming website yeah gave me about
calm because I wanted to add an FAQ and
guess how easy it was
was it super easy it was super easy I
just logged in to Squarespace I liked
just rot wrote a little description
added the text boxes move things around
and just hit publish and it's just like
I'm not sure the best way to describe it
people who haven't created and edited
websites before but you just they have
everything you need built in you don't
need any third party plugins
and it just works they take care of all
of the updates for you very intuitive
it's very intuitive and I think that
like if you're intimidated by making
website you should definitely like just
try it out because you can get a free
trial and there's no downsides of it I
mean before we like published both these
websites that we made evident given
podcast calm and Evan Kaelin gaming I
made a trial website I tried it out I'd
mess around to things and you know one I
didn't like the look of it the trial ran
out I cancelled it and then I wasn't
ready to make another one and then I
went back and I did another trial I
started it I got it to the point where I
was good and then I hit publish and then
BOOM Evan Kaitlyn gaming is that much
more legitimate yeah so there really is
no pressure if having a website of
something that's been on the back of
your mind or maybe you need a website
for that project you're thinking about
doing you should go to Squarespace calm
slash Evan and Kaitlyn podcast for 10%
off your first order and have fun with
your website because it's gonna look
awesome yeah all right so the nine keys
to happiness this isn't something that I
am pitching this is something that I
want to discuss and analyze with you
it's um the age of absurdity from
Michael folly I'm not sure if I'd
recommend the book honestly I mean it
was it was a decent book
and he's kind of like looking at
happiness in this day and age with like
all of the technology changed and the
culture change and all of that and in a
way he kind of seemed a little bit
grumpy and kind of nostalgic for times
past a little bit I would say that but
like it seems mean I mean look up the
reviews for yourself there's a lot of
like you know look it up on Goodreads to
kind of get a general opinion other than
mine but it was kind of an interesting
look into it but one part stood out to
me and I wrote it down because he kind
of looked through all of like the
different quotes about happiness the the
different philosophies all of this thing
all of like this the people's thoughts
on happiness and he kind of condensed
them to nine teams that showed up again
and again and again again again so
wasn't him just saying nine things that
he thinks no are Keys happiness he was
like analyzing data yeah so he he kind
of like looked through all the
information that he could gather and he
says like these are the concepts that
came up again and again and again
through different regions of the world
through different religions through
different philosophies all of that they
all had themes around these nine things
interesting and I'm like huh let's let's
discuss those nine things okay so going
through the list autonomy personal
responsibility detachment understanding
mindfulness transcendence acceptance of
difficulty constant awareness of
mortality and ceaseless striving okay so
should we jump into each of those
because a lot to like wrap your brain
around all at once yeah let's go through
the one-by-one autonomy like I kind of
think of it as the independence and
freedom in terms of like your will your
action so it's like you can you can do
what you want and I think that it's kind
of the same as like the feeling like you
have control over your life yeah kind of
like one one particular circumstance
when I think of it as kind of at work if
your boss is trust you and they let you
accomplish tasks and
in the order you think is best and all
of that I generally am was so much
happier than if I'm being micromanaged
and I've been told all the little
details of what I need to do at what
time and I need to track it all or write
it all down and like Oh both of us had
periods where like we had to go through
like full tracking yeah yeah there's a
time where I had like like count how
much time I spent out in the shop even
though I went out there frequently but
like they had like everyone like in my
department was required to spend a
certain amount of time out on the shop
floor and it wasn't because of me is for
someone else but they had to do for the
whole team kind of just to help one
person and like we all had to track it
and like we did that for a little bit
let me just stop doing but it's being
able to control your own actions I think
does lead to a lot of happiness yeah I
would say that oh I think that's one one
thing was like our situation now for
example we work a lot like a lot longer
hours and we used to but we have full
control over when those hours happen
like we can shift not when those hours
happen but like when things happen we
can shift things around so if like in
the middle of the day we're like hey we
need a brainstorming break to talk about
this project let's go grab a coffee we
can do that we're not like in an office
where we have to stay at our desk yeah
you know I mean I think tied to this I
put these two together because they kind
of like seem very similar and I'm trying
to figure out some of the difference but
autonomy and personal responsibility I'm
not fully sure how he defines personal
responsibility but I think that like
owning up to your own actions like being
true to them and kind of like actively
choosing them and I think that's
slightly different from the independence
and freedom due to like independence and
freedom to of your will or actions is
slightly different than like personally
choosing to do something and owning it
internally and externally I could see
that as well my brain is trying to wrap
around the differences very slight
difference well I think like
personal responsibility so like owning
up to your own actions and decisions I
think again that I think it is related
because it comes back to control kind of
it's like like the decisions you've made
you had control over them and you own up
to that and I think that makes it easier
like if something happens that you
regret it's like well at least I made
the conscious decision to like be where
I am now and I regret something you know
I would or if if I wish something would
have turned out differently it's okay
because I was making the best decision I
could at the time yeah you know yeah and
I think that's like the the personal
responsibility and how it's different
than the freedom to make the choices
yeah so like one one thing that Kalyn
and I say to each other a lot it's like
we have this philosophy of like swimming
instead of floating through life a
little bit and we always want to be
swimming in the direction where we want
to go and like in a way oh there's a
good analogy okay so the difference
between autonomy and personal
responsibility so it's like autonomy is
being able to swim anywhere you want
instead of being in the lane but
personal responsibility is taking the
conscious action to swim in a different
in a certain direction floating so it's
like you're gonna be floating in a big
pool or a small pool or you can be
swimming in a big pool or a small pool
okay so like autonomy is like how big
the poulos you know what I mean no
autonomy isn't how big the pool is
autonomy is do you stay in a lane
someone told you to swim and you go
perpendicular or sideways or squiggle
around yeah yeah yeah but personal
responsibility is do you swim or do you
just float and let the current take you
yeah yeah I mean what else might take
you and a squiggly path or it might take
you down the straight path but yeah just
floating you know I think both are like
important aspects of happiness both of
those like pass my logic test of like
meteo there's an element of happiness
might be biased because we're both the
type of people to quit very
[Music]
to do the things we're doing now yeah I
dunno like yeah these aren't universal
rules they resonate with me but I do
think that some people like order and
you know the I mean some people like
responsibility being taken from them and
being able to like I'm gonna wear that
differently
yeah cuz I think it's not really about
order I like order also yeah I mean and
we have even though there are some
really likes or there's even though
there's some parts of our
responsibilities that are different
every time like every video is different
yeah there are parts of our weeks and
days that are consistent and I like that
and then the other thing you said I
think it's not so much that like some
people like others having the
responsibility I think maybe a better
way to word it is like it's a lot of
pressure to be like fully autonomous of
all of your days and the deciding of
what to do in itself is it to do yeah so
I think like but a million I I had one
employee under me who like that employee
wanted to be told everything that they
would do that day they don't have made
the decision and that made them happier
if they didn't have to do it yes I guess
I guess we're saying the same thing and
just wording it differently um yeah I do
think there is like a desirability of
like taking away the to do of having to
decide what to do yeah heads are hard
okay we can we can revisit those if we
want to but we'll keep on moving mouki
while moving through detachment I don't
know about this and I'm not really fully
sure what he was saying about this maybe
I should have read reread that part of
the book but he was talking about
detachment and how I kind of understand
this is kind of being objective about
things to some degree and like looking
at things clearly and I kind of see that
in some regards kind
almost with the YouTube thing and like
getting caught up in the number and all
of that if you can like let go of it
become slightly detached from it I think
you might be happier I think that also
it's kind of tied to like maybe another
meaning is not taking things personally
detached from stuff yeah
so it could be both it could be like
taking a step back and looking at things
objectively but it could be like just
not taking stuff personally like to use
the YouTube example yeah so looking at
your YouTube subscribers and a detached
as an objective way is like you could
objectively say that's all that was a
lot of people that sub today and even if
it wasn't as many as yesterday that's
that's a lot of people and that's good
yeah you know and it might be easier to
do that if you detached or like YouTube
comments
yeah but or just to continue the analogy
if it's detached isn't like not taking
it personal
you're not like oh my gosh people don't
like my stuff as much as they used to
yeah um
versus just looking at the number for
what it is yeah
also it's like when you get feedback you
know on YouTube or something if you
weren't as detached as might be good
then every like single like negative
thing might get to you really hard and I
know that a lot of YouTube creators
struggle with that yeah and that's like
a big issue for a lot of people whereas
if you can kind of be detached or be
objective about it and kind of like look
at things objectively then I think that
might lead to more happiness yeah in
some ways you can objectively say like
yeah there was one person said a
negative thing but 500 people that said
positive things yeah and so therefore
the negative doesn't matter kind of
you're taking it personally then that
one thing still hurts
I think of detachment as it's not not
caring because you should care about a
lot of things in life but I think
detachment is kind of being able to take
a step back and look at things in a true
way yeah I could see that that's how I
think of
got advice because I think that would be
good advice just make sense yeah
thinking of it in that way yeah okay
next up on the list is understanding I
think that's a really really big thing
because I kind of think of understanding
not just understanding of yourself but
also of others well I guess
understanding that that probably most
people would think of it as others but
also yourself yeah that's true I think
understanding comes with well if you're
looking at like understanding yourself
that comes with like self analyzing and
if you're self analyzing you're you're
probably more likely to be taking
conscious steps towards what makes you
happy because you understand yourself if
you don't understand yourself you may
not be able to take steps that make you
happy but you can even like mix the
understanding and detachment together
and like being able to like take a step
back on your life looking at it kind of
like objectively and then giving
yourself understanding and like
accepting things for yourself that's
true and I think that that would be
something that would increase happiness
that's true and then like for
understanding of others I mean it's like
obvious like you know being an
empathetic person you're going to have
better relationships with other people I
think that's like the more obvious but
also it's like even more immediate like
if you don't put effort into being
understanding of others you might get
upset more unnecessarily oh that's true
like you might take something personally
instead of realizing like oh that person
just had a rough day
yeah yeah or like realizing realizing
that they're trying to give you feedback
they're trying to improve your life and
they might be saying something from a
place of love and concern or care and
that also kind of ties back into
detachment being able to take a step
back from the situation and trying to
understand where they're coming from and
and then like appreciate that instead of
getting caught up and like exactly like
you're getting
offensive or anything like that you can
like say hey I appreciate that I
understand that and yeah it's a positive
thing instead of a negative thing yeah
that's true yeah okay
one more mindfulness I definitely think
that this has a lot to do with happiness
yeah that's interesting because I kind
of think of mindfulness very similarly
as well I guess there's different so
many of these have overlaps cuz I know
yeah part of mindfulness is also kind of
like understanding yourself I think a
little I think there's some overlaps
there like being mindful of your own
feelings and where you are and but then
there's mindfulness as in like being
present yeah I think a lot of time is
being present you know because I think
that one thing that's come up again and
again and like these because I have such
a nerd but um you know I think I've
talked about this in one past episode I
have a life cheat sheet where I kind of
like compile advice I've gotten from
books or TED talks or anything like that
and a lot of people have talked about
how being mindful of your day being
appreciative in the moment and being
present is a huge part of being happy if
you're always thinking of the next thing
or you're not or always thinking of the
past thing yeah if you're thinking of
future things or past things or other
things anything other than the moment
it's a lot easier to not be happy yeah
and if you are able to be present and
mindful in the moment it's almost always
an increase in happiness yeah that makes
sense and it's been something that I
have like checked myself on multiple
times like sometimes when I'm not being
mindful and not being present I'm like
I'm not enjoying this really good
situation I'm in right now like
sometimes like you know we'll go out to
dinner and we'll be like Bobo still be
in work mode we'll still be in work mode
because we just came from work then
we're about to go back to work and you
know when we are most of the time we are
fairly present with each other yeah and
when we are like very present we'll have
interesting conversations or we'll get
excited about something in the future or
we'll make plans or like well engage
with each other or discuss something
about the day or you know all sorts of
things and it's a really interesting fun
time but if we're still kind of
distracted when we're like planning to
do Zara like getting into productive
modes then that's so funny it's like all
of the examples that we're giving our
all around work because like there
aren't that many personal time things we
do anymore
yeah or let's say you're on vacation
yeah you don't want to be thinking oh
that's tough you gotta do when you get
home yeah and if you're able to be
mindful and present in a moment then
you're gonna enjoy the triple and that
time a lot more I think one thing and I
do I do generally agree with that but I
do think there are certain situations
where I feel like being distracted is
more fun but that's like for example if
I'm like cooking or if you're sanding I
really enjoy having like a podcast on or
like sometimes I'll call my mom and
we'll just chitchat I think if that has
been mindful
yeah distracted distracting from your
task at hand because like I think that
like what you're thinking of is being
present in the moment it's like well you
could just you know enjoy chopping this
toy popping or enjoy sanding and like if
you have thoughts to think go for it you
know like there are I'm just like I'll
put in my headphones and I just won't
turn on the podcast cuz you have you
have thoughts and you're spending time
with your thoughts and it's like if you
if you like either way you can be
mindful in either situation you know you
could be like sometimes when I'm in the
garage just doing sanding with a good
podcasts on I think hmm
this moment is really nice you know I
see and the moment is enjoying the
podcast while sanding yes yes and I'm
like I like this that's interesting
whereas like if your I'll have to sand
and I want to do other things then you
could like really resent the sanding
that's interesting that is that does
seem like a more accurate way to think
about it because that was like my one
loophole I was like well I don't there's
some tasks that I don't enjoy unless I
have a distraction I think be mindful
and being present in the moment doesn't
mean like fully focusing on the one
thing that you're doing but like like
like this this might be another example
and it's it's it's a strange mix of
everything but let's say the
two of us and we never do this could be
never watch shows in the background but
like let's say that the two of us have
like a show on in the background no no
no we have done something like that okay
yeah so so we were we were in we were at
home we were cleaning out a closet we
had a show that like was a more
background show on the background would
chat with each other I was working on
like setting up a cabinet and Caitlin
was working on clothes so we had clothes
going on
we had TV we had cabinet and we were
chatting but we are very present in that
moment and now super enjoyable that's
true yeah so maybe it like that that's
not interesting because I don't know why
I didn't click for me that like having
distractions can be part of the moment
yeah but I guess that is different than
like like sanding and listening to a
podcast is different than sanding and
just wishing you were doing something
else yeah like if you're standing and
you like you wish with all of your being
that you were just playing Minecraft
still or something like that
then that's not good - enjoy the might
be a podcast yeah you can be like you
know what I'm really excited to play
Minecraft when it's time to play
Minecraft it'll wait for me the game is
infinite and it will always bring me joy
you know ok so here's an interesting
thing so a lot of times our breaks are
when we're doing just kind of like
normal life to do that have to be done
but aren't work yes so like if we need
to pick up around the house or like if
we need to cook something or like if we
need to go run an errand yeah it's like
or the dentist ha ha but that's like a
break yeah work and like even though
those things like when we were working 9
to 5 and I had to go grocery shopping
I'd be like I just want to get home cuz
it seems like an extra to do yeah
and now even though sometimes like I
don't want to go grocery shopping just
cuz I'm I feel like a deadline or
something yeah um but now it's like oh I
mean I take like a grocery shopping
break and like you can call your mom or
listen to a podcast you can be present
sorry had to burp a you be present wall
you do that and you can really enjoy
that time yeah instead of looking at it
as like a to do yeah that's interesting
loophole closed yeah yeah but I think
that we talked to the most about
mindfulness that's really interesting
interesting yeah but I think that like
you know again like you're saying so
many of these things tie in together so
like being mindful especially in
combination with some of these things
can really boost the happiness of the
other thing that's like let's say that
you are choosing to like like for the
two of us sometimes we're like okay we
need to get worked on we needed to get
brainstorm and done but let's do it
while we drive to this really amazing
coffee shop and let's do the work at the
coffee shop because that will help us
like enjoy it more if you're being
mindful of like you know what I'm making
this choice and I have the autonomy to
do so then like if you're mindful of the
position that you're in and how lucky
you are to be able to do that yeah
that'll make you even more happy at all
layers about what you're doing that's
true and if you're present in the moment
during the drive while you get there and
when you drive back the whole trip can
be experience instead of like some
people don't like driving but like if we
have something interesting to talk about
during the drive like oh I'm glad we
have a 20 minute drive ahead of us yeah
you know it's like it's it can be a
positive thing also yeah it's
interesting it's very interesting yeah
okay
next one okay this is like uh you know
it's a little bit hard and we probably
won't dive too much into this I don't
know maybe we will but transcendence the
existence or experience beyond the
normal or physical and I think that like
you know in general on our podcast and
on our channel and all of that we try to
stay away from controversial things and
I don't think religion is that
controversial but I don't think that
this is necessarily just religion this
could be anything
actually the way that I read like the
first thing that popped into mind when I
saw this is
like if you are going camping or your
like out in the wilderness you just like
take a moment to really appreciate like
being part of the universe yes I'd
yourself in thinking of like how small
you are
yeah like wow there's a lot of stars up
there and how giant the universe is and
how it keeps on getting bigger every
second it really doesn't matter if our
next video gets this many views there
that many views like look at all those
stars so it helps with detachment it
helps with detachment hahaha but that's
kind of what pops into my mind when I
think of like the so we have written
down transcendence existence or
experience beyond the normal or physical
no transcendence all he wrote is
transcendence
oh so that's like you're what you what
you interpret it yeah cuz I was like
what what what is it like the technical
definition of transcendence and I looked
it up and it was the existence or
experience beyond the normal or physical
but like you said like beyond the normal
so to some people it might be going
camping seeing a double rainbow and
wondering what it all means and being
present in that moment and appreciating
the autonomy that you had to go camping
at that moment and see that double
rainbow and wondering what it means not
knowing what it means and reveling in
that yeah that's totally it and not too
far off for my example actually that
just reminds me of there's one point
where we were both in California at the
same summer along here in the same place
at the same time with our families but
we weren't dating yet and we saw the
same double rainbow and we text each
other or do we like post photos on
Facebook we both posted photos instantly
I say we saw the scenes we made the same
joke about our minds were already one
it's true double mind I kind of thought
of like it's not it's not really
transcendent I don't know but like I did
kind of have like thoughts about how
crazy it is that among all of the
billions of people we found each other
we are such a great match we have so
many same brain thoughts that's true
and that's a crazy thing
crazy and we met in college and I almost
didn't even go to that college it was
like a last minute choice yeah little
switcheroo yes it is crazy yeah that's a
good example too yeah okay another thing
that I've thought about a lot that's
recently everything I read this again
but like all of today I read this I
prepared this podcast earlier and today
and all today I've kind of been this has
been stuck in my head but acceptance of
difficulty yes I think it's a great
thing to be aware of like just accept
that a lot of things in life are
difficult and that's just how it is yeah
which I don't think is it sounds
negative but I think that life is
happiness
yeah exactly but yeah I don't think of
it as a negative thing and it reminds me
actually of I'm pretty sure this is on
your life cheat sheet I think goes from
a TED talk but like you can better
experience happiness when you are facing
struggles yeah because like you kind of
need the lower to appreciate the higher
yeah yeah yeah you can definitely
experience higher peaks after some
valleys I mean I think we've also talked
about this before so I think that we
have this theory that everyone has a
base level of happiness on like a scale
and they usually return to that base
unless something dramatic happens and
their base happiness like slides up and
down but like in everyone's days and
lives you know it goes up and down but
one thing that was very interesting they
did a study of people who have gone
through traumatic life experiences where
like they thought that their life would
be ruined after it but when they are
checked in afterwards you know it's like
their base level of happiness was
relatively unaffected by this thing that
you'd think would really change your
happiness that's interesting that's kind
of what I was talking about but that is
also very interesting yeah I was talking
more about like and this kind of good is
tied to like think about retirement
blame yeah like a lot of people when
they first start working it's like it's
very hard to get used to having a
nine-to-five and you don't have summer
breaks and it's just like oh my
gosh it's gonna be so long till I retire
yeah but most people when they get to
retirement it it seems like a lot of
people don't actually enjoy it cuz you
don't have like a challenge every day
yeah you know yeah and and that's not
the only reason there's other things but
um I think like having a challenge and
overcoming a challenge gives you
happiness and I think that's related to
like acceptance of difficulty yes like
there will be difficulties and you can
use them to like increase your happiness
I want to do a whole podcast at some
point about how life is like a video
game that's almost what I have this
podcast beat but if you think about it
like the acceptance of difficulty no one
likes games that are too easy yeah it's
like let's say that you're playing a
role-playing game like Diablo for
example and you started out the game and
you had all of your God level gear and
equipment and all of that and you
couldn't adjust the difficulty any
harder yeah well you just quit you
wouldn't even play it yeah the
acceptance of difficulty it's like like
realizing that like not that video not
that life is a video game and there's
some levels of difficulty that aren't
that don't lead to happiness that that
are really unfortunate and I wish that
everyone had like you know you know
opportunities presented to themselves
and some people didn't have to go
through such difficulties in life but I
think everyone if you accept the life is
difficult it will increase your
happiness
yeah well that kind of also goes back to
like expectation versus reality yeah a
little bit and what was it happiness is
happiness is expectation versus reality
yeah yeah reality - what your
expectation was yeah something like that
but like if you're if what you expect
and what reality are are different then
you're probably not gonna be happy about
it yeah so it's kind of a little bit of
that - yeah one or one more constant
awareness of mortality that
morbid it is I mean I see it it's like
they live each day like it was your last
kind of a little bit I'm not sure if
that be smart because I think that like
one one note that I kind of wrote next
to it like my interpretation of it and
this was actually from back when I read
the book but I might have also been like
pulling from different TED Talks but how
I interpret it was like to break the
routine every now and then to live
intensely like live purposefully and
stuff like that because like you know
kind of goes back to like the swimming
verse floating you know like if you
always assume that later on you're gonna
do something yeah you know like an you
always put things off and you just stay
in the same lane you may never do them
you may never do them so I think that
like yeah knowing that your time is
limited makes you use that time more
wisely maybe instead of constant
awareness of mortality when you say that
constant awareness and joy that you're
alive mortality because it's like
constant awareness yeah yeah I mean I
think that we are are like you have like
a reminder that pops up on your phone
every like 10 minutes like you're gonna
die one day it might help you appreciate
what you have maybe like the constant
awareness of mortality will help with
mindfulness it definitely will help
boost it a little bit mm-hmm I think
also certain things maybe there's a bit
of a stretch but like for example when
we quit our jobs to do this we knew that
we would regret not trying more than we
would regret trying yeah
failing and it my brain had a connection
for that to the awareness of mortality
we're just we're that we are running out
of time in life which is constant
awareness of mortality that's like
you're always constantly running out of
time
it's like there's this movie where it
was kind of like future dystopia where
everyone had like a counter of how much
life they had left or something like I
don't know and like that really make you
aware of how much time you have to live
I don't know but yeah being aware that
like your time is limited and you should
make good use of it to a certain degree
yeah I don't know yeah and like you only
have one life so you know go for the
things you want to go for yeah I'm glad
we did
oh man okay ceaseless driving that kind
of ties into what we were just talking
about like and then again ties into like
man the swimming and floating analogy
they're like I think of a lot yeah that
sums up so much of this like are you a
swimmer or are you a floater how that is
wrong with floating at times but like it
seems like a lot of this ties into like
do you want to be more passive in life
or do you want to be more active yeah in
life yeah and I'm glad that we are like
you know both of us strangely I'm not
sure how many people I've met like you
in this regard but like when I was I'm
trying to remember the earliest in life
that I remember thinking this but I
think it was like when I was younger
than 10 years old I'm not sure how much
younger it was but I always kind of met
people and when I met them I kind of
like thought about like what I liked
about them and what I didn't like about
them and that kind of sounds weird but
like when you're growing up you're
figuring out who you want to be and I
constantly want to be striving even from
a young age even though it might not
have been so consciously this but I when
I was younger I threw my entire life I
always wanted to be striving towards the
person I want to be and how do I go
about that how do I like who don't want
to be how do want to live my life and
how do I get there I've constantly been
kind of like trying to move forward in
that direction well I think one thing
that is common between the two of us
we've both moved a lot when you move a
lot you have an opportunity to reinvent
yourself every time so you kind of do
think about it and like I definitely
reinvented myself
too many moves yeah and it wasn't
necessary like some things were maybe a
little deeper some things were kind of
shallow like I'm gonna start shopping at
Hot Topic now but like it was I think it
is something that you're given the
opportunity to change yourself more
easily when you're going like when you
move a lot not that you can't but like
when you're a kid it is kind of I think
more intimidating or harder to reinvent
yourself um if you're if you're not
moving and meeting like hold new groups
of friends yeah there is a sorry I was
gonna go on like a complete tangent so I
was gonna throw off your train in a big
way okay so recently I was listening to
an interview on the create unknown yeah
and they were talking about the question
of like why don't successful youtubers
or and content creators retire how is
this a really fascinating topic and I
think that one big part of it is you
know ceaselessly striving and winning
that's kind of addictive you know like
when you're on that upswing and you're
constantly trying to grow and you know
win at all these like metrics and stuff
like that it's hard to stop because that
that is a source of happiness is a
pretty obvious one you know but I think
that on the negative side of this is
what if you you do succeed you are at
that peak and you realize that you've
reached that and there's nowhere else to
strive really yeah so it's like make
sure you're striving in the right
direction because I think some people
just strive for like numbers and like
money or success or whatever it is and I
think that when we started out this
venture the striving that we wanted to
do was to change our life improve our
life spend more time together find
creative fulfillment find like all these
other types of fulfillment
financials were like let's just make
enough money to survive and yeah stuff
like let's to make sure that we have all
of our bills covered we don't need to
worry about like you know are we gonna
make ends meet after this period of time
or what if like YouTube falls and we
don't have enough money in our nest egg
or what if our savings aren't good or
whatever it is it's like we had minimal
requirements around money and the thing
we've been striving for this whole time
is we want to get our life to a good
point
yeah and part of that is you know the
financial side but that's that's the
goal wasn't the finances the goal was
our life yeah
and it is interesting cuz you know it so
I think people can't easily get caught
up in the finances or get caught up in
just like the the numbers like the
subscribers of the views and it's
interesting cuz sometimes we'll get
asked by like family members like so so
you know when you when do you think you
guys will be able to slow down when you
get to this mini-subs
when you get to this many subs and our
answer is always like it's not about how
many subs as we get to it we're not
aiming for a snit like number of subs
we're aiming to get we're like you know
we can stop working in the evening like
that's the goal is like you know we want
to get to a good work-life balance and
sometimes that requires more work
upfront yeah and that's kind of where we
are right now you know we we haven't hit
that work-life balance and you know even
though I know this isn't an idea I'm
coming up with independently but we
listen to the making a podcast and one
thing that Bob from I like to make stuff
who is also making a podcast says is
that like it's not a balance it's not a
single balance just seesaw yeah it's
like you had you're constantly balancing
so I know there's never like that one
point where it's like okay we got it
like you're constantly shifting yeah
but we're definitely not at the point
where we have the flexibility to shift
as needed right now
yeah and that's kind of what we're
working towards like we got the working
together check that was the main reason
we started the channel like lots of
creative fulfillment
you know and sometimes we're like ooh
like it would be really cool to start
this other and we have to try to resist
but we do get created fulfilment from
the stuff we do but yeah it's like the
balance is the part we're still striving
for yeah well really it's like hi are
you guys we don't want to complain we
don't have become a complain cast
because we are really lucky but like
there are some things that we want to
change yeah yeah it's also because we're
swimmers they're always like what can we
change
let's keep changing things yeah because
like if we had of like just started the
YouTube channel and stopped there we
probably might be at that good work-life
balance point we probably would be we
we'd still be doing more instructional
videos which are a little bit faster to
like edit and film I think it's a little
bit faster yeah
but I think that we'd still be like we
wouldn't have the gaming channel we
wouldn't have this podcast yeah but I
think that because we are swimmers and
we are like long-term planners and stuff
and we do try to like understand like
not that anyone understands YouTube or
like you know and and everyone stinks at
predicting what their happiness is going
to be in the future you know it's like
humans in general aren't the best at
like predicting what will make them
happy in the future but I think that one
thing that we did know is we wanted to
be flexible we wanted variety and again
we wanted that autonomy with our content
because like we knew that if we put
ourselves too much into a box we get
borden we'd get bored long term and we
want to set ourselves up with the
flexibility that we need to continue
doing this for the rest of our lives and
we wanted to build that into our plan
from the beginning as much as possible
and I think that with with the balance
we have now we have that is a lot so
what one of these like nine things did
you resonated the most with you and what
were you kind of like yeah um so I think
the mindfulness resonated a lot yeah
the I mean these are very similar as we
mentioned before but like the autonomy /
personal responsibility yeah like
choosing what to do with your time and
being active in choosing rather than
like passive and I also think that yeah
like like there's a lot of hard choices
in life you know and I think that like I
like changing jobs or changing careers
that's a big thing and and you know if
if you know you have and hopefully
everyone has these opportunities
available to themselves but like you
know when we were working on our careers
there were a lot of options for us in
terms of work we had the autonomy to do
that we could have changed jobs we could
have changed careers or whatever but
like the personal responsibility to
actively choose it it's it's tough but
you know we like one of my first jobs I
wasn't doing much it was a fairly easy
job and I took the responsibility on
myself to choose to move to another job
a startup company where I was working
longer hours everything was harder but I
was happy with that choice because I
made it actively and I don't know where
I was going with that oh yeah we were
talking about like which ones resonated
the most oh yeah and that was like an
example of where the autonomy and
personal responsibility paid off I think
the thing I'm still coming to terms with
after eating through the list is like
what the difference between autonomy and
personal possibility is I dunno they're
different
I'd agree that both are important yeah
but I wonder if they could be combined
into one I think so I think but I still
think that those two combined as one and
mindfulness are probably the ones that
resonated with me the most what about
you
I think understanding is another well
actually that they're all really good
they're all really good I think I just
want we like the ones that happiness
happiness that I had the most to like I
had the most feelings about or I don't
know or that I could rap the most into I
think understanding is something that
affects a lot of people and it's
something that makes a lot of people
angry especially like politically right
now and socially right now like there's
a lot of anger caused by the lack of
understanding it's a big one so I'm not
sure how much I have to say about it if
I do them that's a really big one like
let's do a harmless example that
everyone can relate to you're driving to
work and someone like pulls ahead of you
or like is in a rush or something like
that I think it's really easy to
anonymize people when they're in cars
because it's a car you know but like if
you understand that there's a person in
there they might be in a rush they might
have had a horrible day they have to
poop maybe they have to poop and they
really want it they really want to go
for it you know it's like like if you
know they're Russian you're I hate you
do you as long as you're being safe and
following the laws if you want like rush
home to go poo I'm not in a rush so go
for it you know and like having a little
bit of understanding and care helps you
not get upset which definitely the lack
of upsetness is a plus and happiness
yeah yeah that's true I think that also
an acceptance of difficulty it's
something that we have kind of always
done so I think that we kind of take it
for granted to some degree but I think
that it is really hard it is a important
one because well I think like I've I've
had like friends and acquaintances that
would never say yes to opportunities
because they were difficult
yeah and I think if you accept
difficulty you're more likely to like
like with most opportunities there's
some form of difficulty or challenge
yeah it's not often just an opportunity
that has no cost at all yeah to you
there's usually some difficulty involved
and if you accept that difficulty is
just part of life I think you're less
likely to be scared of those challenges
and you're more likely to like take
opportunities yeah but even little
things like little things that might
have upset you but instead you're just
like it's just that's just how life is
so the other day our toilet broke we're
filming the intro skit for for our heart
legs with hidden storage in which we
throw fake dollar bills into the toilet
tank yeah so something about the you
know floater and plunger system got
messed up I know what it is now so I'll
tell it and but like something was
messed up and that could have upset me
but I'm like you know what it is what it
is and it will either be difficult or
easy I'll just like look it up I'll take
it on and I'll fix it and it turned out
not to be that hard at all I just needed
to clear some debris from one of the
seals and it worked fine but like being
okay with that it's okay that's life
things break and that's fine you know
yeah I don't know yeah sounds like big
things and small things it changes your
day that's true yes I think that's
that's nothing I think like we could
keep on talking about this forever but
like power into this podcast so thing of
the week
my thing of the week is interstellar
five five five five it's maybe a very
very obscure thing but um most people
have heard of Daft Punk the the band the
two artists who create amazing songs one
of their might like probably my favorite
album is the discovery album it's just
so good and what you might not know is
there's an entire movie around that
album it's so cool it's amazing it was
one of the first things I watched with
you yeah you showed it to me the second
movie we watched together it was like
spirited away then inner seller but like
they were able to take this album and
turn it into an amazingly cohesive music
video movie story it's so cool and like
I still think about it sometimes well
that's why it that's why I choose Daniel
because I mean one of the songs popped
into your head the other day and we've
been singing it since then like I had to
look up and like replay a few moments
from the movie online because we have it
we purchased it
oh well I'll put a link below I'm not
sure where you can buy it now cuz it's
such an obscure thing I don't know I
hope they have digitally somewhere
online yeah but it's if you love so it
is done in the style of like an anime
it's really good like anime but uh oh
man it's just if you want it like a
movie length music video with the cool
story yeah I'm not sure how like how
actively you can watch it I mean we act
so if you like alternative movies based
around albums especially if you're
someone that likes Daft Punk yeah yeah
yeah and you like extra appreciate oh
yeah if you've never if you're like not
a fan obviously it's basically like the
best music video ever that's over an
hour
oh yeah okay what's what's your pick of
the week my pick of the week is if
you're watching the video I'm pulling
off
well not pulling off it sounds like I'm
taking it off I have our hoodies my
thing of the week is our E&K hoodies we
finally have hoodies now because
everyone's been asking and we really
wanted them to yeah took us a while to
like figure out what what honey design
okay like let's do sip up hoodies
because those are like I don't know most
of my hoodies are zip up so I was like
let's do zip ups but then you know we
work with a print-on-demand company so
we're limited in like what options we
can choose and you couldn't easily print
on the front and all of our designs I
wanted to print on the front yeah and so
we put it off for a while and then I was
like oh these pullover ones got really
good ratings and so we finally puts them
together we had to like wait to get our
sample orders in before we wanted to say
anything to anyone cuz we want to make
sure that they were super comfy and
stuff and make sure they wear well and
everything but I love them they're my
thing of the week oh and we got we made
sweatpants - I'm also wearing those yeah
so we have a make fail hoodie a words
are hard hoodie and we got a request for
a supervisor in space hoodie so we got
that one too and I'm these sweatpants
say one sleep later down the leg because
that was another popular bust so so I
think it's cool that like I don't know
if we mentioned this on the podcast
before but like we used to work with the
local screen printing company and like
keep our own inventories and it was so
hard to like keep accurate stock for
what we would need and we only had one
t-shirt design in one color and even
with that it was so hard but since we do
print on demand
I can literally be like oh yeah that
person wants a size kid size um it's
dangerous to go alone take this
supervisor t-shirt sure I'll just do
that real quick here's your plan is
available in like all sorts of sizes if
you need like women sizes or like large
or small plus sizes yeah so it's it's
so nice being able to just like make as
many designs as we want you know we can
do special things for people if it's not
something that we have on the store yeah
um you know it's just nice inventory
whatever things print on demand so we
appreciate you guys understanding when
it takes a little bit longer to ship or
you know we can't do returns and stuff
like that there are some way less than
we make way less but well you know we
can we can accommodate a lot of people
in this way t-shirts I used to do
graphic design stuff so it's fine like
getting to designer cheese yeah okay one
good podcast the podcast podcast good
podcasts the podcast good podcast the
podcast I really like doing topics on
things where we can like get into like
serious discussions because like when I
came up with this I was like I'm just
really excited to talk to you about this
stuff because these are things that we
like talking about we need to talk about
them we analyze life a lot we analyze
life a lot our own lives
odubel lives like life in general like
what's the meaning of life and we do and
that comes from being mindful and
analyzing things point number five guys
how do I do an outro again every outer
of the podcast I'm like thank you
everyone for listening
you can like and subscribe on youtube or
you can rate us on itunes let me share
appreciate that share this podcast with
a person who you think would appreciate
it yeah I look forward to see you next
time bye
[Music]